foreign
[Music]
a G wagon just dropped my girl off she
said it was a bolt
quite sweet
nah bro that's a file that's a bio
[Laughter]
oh God I can't believe that
laughs
no bro that's violating
[Laughter]
I don't know why that's so funny to me a
G wagon just dropped my girl off she
said it was a bolt the audacity
quote sweet
we will spend the whole night requesting
and cancel until she gets the same bolt
for me hundreds percent I'm swear from
that wow Sam show me the driver send him
a tip facts send him a five-star review
and a tip right now show me
a G wagon dropped my girl off a G-Wagon
that's a real man your girl's been
spending the thing with a real man and
he dropped it to a
yeah she's got no time for you she got
no time normally I knew you were gonna
ask that oh it's a bolt she the lie was
already there a bolt
no bolt exactly
she doesn't rate you enough to even
entertain the whole thing the whole it's
a bolt shut up shut up he's my new man a
G wagon
the audacity I actually can't believe it
I couldn't be confronted with that in my
humble picket fence yeah yeah I'm
looking for the thing and a G wagon
pulls up
I can't see who's inside I see her hop
out yeah hop out I'm just like dang
front seat offs oh front seat offs yeah
and she skips back in the yard no no I'm
I'm putting the padlock on the thing I'm
putting the chain yeah yeah yeah she
will burst through like fam sure open it
below what and she'll see my eyes yeah g
wagon yeah who's that babes don't be
stupid it's a bowl yeah request it again
yeah request it again request it or
you're not getting back into this yard I
promise because he can afford a yard for
you really it's clear G wagon clearly
you don't need this that's 300 racks
mini mini
um so this one acts as if you're my girl
yeah just reply to what I'm saying all
right
babe
breathe in
breathe out
it's over
wow
[Music]
literally us
pardon
you can never play with me like that
am I a toy to you breathe in breathe out
what's it all about it's over it's over
no no no no no no no oh [__] that's
sweet in me oh Jesus
white people can identify 500 dog breeds
but we get two black co-workers mixed up
oh fam did I ever tell you
did I ever tell you bro if we were in a
team meeting one time at my job sweating
and we had this [__] manager buff we
had to go get this hot get in this
huddle and it was me and one of a black
I've never told you before I can't stop
laughing
[__] he got us all together and as me
and one of a black guy yeah he looked
nothing like me dreads yeah dreads he
had dreads everything man said it we're
doing them we're doing the manager's
meeting yeah go through he's talking
talking how about my Mango's name's Neil
waste man he goes guys guys guys guys
pointed at me and then goes Cool
Runnings
he did what is that bad he said guys
guys guys Cool Runnings he got their
attention
of the whole office and said oh wait
guys guys quick tip quick joke quick
quick before they move Cool Runnings
separate Cool Runnings Cool Runnings oh
HR is the r I'll be speaking bro bro
what
because obviously the next answer is so
when was his funeral
because I stood there I was like I can't
yeah I can't do anything because I need
this job
cool
running you're equipped before they
separate quick joke quick
Cool Runnings brother
what did the other brother say or do in
fact we looked at each other we looked
at each other Asia one of them ones just
held it like running I needed this Pete
we both need this P wow you've never
told me that otherwise called Michael he
got sacked like a week later I'm
surprised he didn't come finally I'll
just talk him up oh my goodness that's
um that's treacherous this one is more
of like a paragraph so I'll just read it
out as like a mini story type of thing
I remember I took this girl out once
um to a nice little restaurant called
Ruth Chris the little bird started
ordering drinks appetizers steak shrimp
salmon and goldfish mind you I only had
three don't don't don't just don't just
don't I don't understand sorry sir don't
know sorry they're serving goldfish but
we'll keep it moving we'll keep it
moving
my tonsils were sweating
I don't know where they're selling that
it's Haram that's all I know salmon and
goldfish mind you all I had was 350 and
my car was on E my car was already no
so I'm sitting there eating my Caesar
salad getting nervous about who um about
the bill so I said who the [__] is
eating all of this food she said oh I'm
gonna take some home for my roommate I
went to the bathroom and never came back
fast forward five years today we got
introduced to our new supervisor I look
up and there she is stood there staring
at me and said Hey Stephen well I guess
I'll be on indeed tonight
oh
indeed Raw
yes brother indeed
yeah yeah wow that's a roller coaster of
events it is the thing is it's as soon
as she says that Hey Stephen same with
the Bible saying I'm jumping straight in
there who are you what do you mean your
friend what do you mean your housemate
fat what do you mean I'll pick out where
we left off five years later what do you
actually mean you're a housemate this is
your new supervisor Shelly this is the
team Oh Hey Stephen what do you mean
you're bringing stuff home for your
housemate broke what does that even mean
I'm a ghost
let's talk about that first and foremost
who orders goldfish
steak Lobster and goldfish for your
housemate how dare you of course I left
you of course and any anyone else in
here would as well [__] I work in a
shop
you know what my salary is saying it's
been five years and you've come straight
in as my supervisor man I don't have
prospects
I had to dip a fax a hat to dip Jesus oh
what'd you expect from me literally what
do you expect this is relative yeah told
this girl I didn't have a car she saved
me in her phone as legs I've seen that
one before wow even funny brother
legs people take public transport you
know it's calm it's cold is gone I don't
have a car she saved me in her phone as
legs that's not even okay while Guan
legs
Mr don't have a vehicle
Mr not knowing what 10 and 2 means
wow wow legs that's uncalled for legs
11. 11.
11. that's uncalled for no I can't I
can't
I just can't deal with stuff like that
I'm sorry no I couldn't be treated I
can't be spoken to you like speaking of
slight tangent uh Jay told me about this
thing the other day
it's so frustrating because there's
nothing there's nothing man them these
day can do to retaliate without
admitting their bank account was empty
and if your bank account's empty in
apparently in 2023 of a bank account if
you've got a set of balls on you and
your bank account's empty you don't have
a voice in here okay you hit me so he
was telling me about he saw this post
about a girl saying what she expects in
a relationship in a man okay so
basically uh I'm gonna I'm paraphrasing
okay okay but she said basically like I
want 300 days a year I want my man to
make x amount I think it was like 650k a
year we're talking dollars or pounds
dollars I think still what do you mean
you hope so that's still like 500. I
mean it's like four something threesome
it's like four something
it's high fat is it not let me check 650
in Dollars to Pounds 650
000. oh is it that close now
oh mad
hang on hang on hang on yeah 650
650 000 dollars
to pounds why does it keep going to
[__]
just these 65 he comes to 65 650
000.
dollars in pounds 532 532 say less ain't
no one making 532.
532 yeah yeah say less so anyway she
said I want a man who makes 650 yeah a
year yeah I want
um three holidays a year I want two kids
both from surrogate mothers because I'm
not trying to get preg I'm not trying to
do pregnancy twice both of us are good
Mothers and um
what is it both since I've got my first
300 days a year 650k a year out and two
nannies one for inside and one for
outside oh my goodness
um and then she said in the in the
caption
any basically any guy that's commenting
here you're broke
you're just sour and broke no you're
just sour and broke and then all the
girls in the comments were like facts
facts and the thing is is like it's
actually kind of true it's not but like
just on a Persona thing yeah
if you've got energy and time to be in
the comments cussing and fighting your
case you're broke you are bro yeah yeah
vexing but that doesn't mean I can't
speak
yeah big man you're just here because
you're broke yeah but I'm allowed to
speak yeah
I'm all right the man I'm looking for is
not in his comments yeah yeah yeah
you're broke it's annoying bro if you
can't be broke in 2023 it's actually
upsetting actually can't be is upsetting
because why are you talking you're broke
just tell me your bro that's the answer
to everything just tell me you're broke
just tell me you're bro sorry I don't
have change sorry I just don't have
change for you today
stop annoying me
wow do you remember that one of course
do you remember that one sorry I don't
have change
sorry I don't have change while gone
babe sorry I've got no change you're
broke
um legs where's your car are you walking
to or from your car
because I just saw you get out of
Waterloo Station
so you can't be talking to me oh
so if you're right and none of these
things exist in my life offs oh but
it's not even funny it's not even fair
it's not fair is the thing it's not fair
it could be funny it's just not fair and
that's 650 ain't no one's making that's
unrealistic I saw a thing never doubt I
can't remember I spoke about it already
um I saw a thing the other day it was
like a guy was going around it was in
the UK asking like
um to be in the top one percent of
earners yeah how much money do you think
you have to make okay everyone was like
a million two million five million some
guy said one percent in the UK in the UK
to be in the top one percent of earners
in the UK how much do you think that is
and then um yeah I don't think it's even
that much that high fat yeah taking us
what do you think it is I think it's
like your sensible human being and you
people were saying like a milli some
people saying couple men some guy said a
billion oh somebody say 500k uh 700k top
one percent in the top one percent of
earners in the UK I would probably say
something around the realm of maybe 125
103. oh Fair 103 000 a year you're the
top one percent really yep wow yep so
less obviously we're in the top North
poem
I'm playing but yeah fam
650 532 yeah delusional she's delusional
no one's reaching that I've seen that
money before no one's making that unless
you're an athlete
yeah yeah you're not making it yeah yeah
and if I'm an athlete I ain't got time
for these requests I ain't got time for
you because you want your Twitter yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
anything else yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because seeking upper echelon things
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but this is
interesting we'll get back onto this
thing this is interesting I actually had
an interesting conversation with someone
about this yeah this was intrigued from
like a female perspective yeah yeah yeah
um
and is interesting in terms of like
what I feel like the disconnect between
men and women is when it comes to that
kind of thing because in terms of like
the automatic
the automatic response to this is from
my experience the automatic response to
a guy like
begrudging that kind of like request is
not that and like the automatic response
from a female's like you're broke and if
you had the money you wouldn't that
would never be your demeanor yeah
because the man I'm looking for can hear
all this stuff and he's securing us and
he's like financially like well off
enough that this is an issue to him so
he would like yeah minor do it but it's
like what I think what females Miss is
that like that's not it's not that he's
broke it's the fact that like guys are
very much
who are you
like guys need to want to do it guys
want to want to like
throw stuff at that girl yeah yeah they
want to like they want their like they
want to feel like she does everything
for me I love her I love her she does
this for me she does that for me she
does this for me she takes care of all
my needs she is like a provider to me
like she's the mother of my kids you're
telling me you're not even trying to
hold them you'll tell me you want a
nanny for inside and outside and
obviously with all this I'm assuming you
want to clean up I'm assuming we've got
a cut yeah yeah so what are you doing
bringing to this table why do I want
yeah what what do I want to do for you
nothing nothing you're just asking for
this is about yeah you just look good
yeah so what else like why what makes me
want to do it it's not about whether I
can or can't it's like what makes me
want to do it because like you're just
saying [__] and there's plenty of other
women that will like earn that where
they they're not coming in here saying I
want this I want that one there's
someone that it's just like I just want
to care for you I want to love you I'm
looking to care for you and the man's
like say less I'm gonna do it up for you
oh we're staying on holiday I'm gonna do
the most to you yeah yeah yeah so I feel
like there's always a disconnect because
like yeah the women are always like well
if your attitude is disgruntled then
you're broke and it's like I'm not broke
but I I don't know you yeah I deserve a
voice in this battle Yeah because I have
a voice in this platform yeah so allow
me to speak yeah literally allow me to
speak oh yeah yeah the Brokenness is
actually horrible it's a it's such an
easy like stab for women oh you're just
broke yeah but you're broke so and it's
annoyed because you're broke there's
literally nothing else you can say
because unless and then you get to the
point where you open up your apps like I
will show you yeah
oh my God here we go Jeremy accounts I'm
seeing stuff
there's not a number in there that you
can show her that will shut her up yeah
there is there actually isn't a number
in there that you can show her
because you start looking at your
account thing is this enough yeah yeah
is this enough do I actually have enough
yeah you're looking in there and it's
like I don't even know it's 14 bags in
there and you're like I think she might
laugh at this
and you start thinking what if I move my
savings over
I can hold at least yeah yeah yeah if
there's a humble 20 she might believe
I've got multiple accounts
yeah oh God yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if
I bring if I drink for the monzo
so yeah there's literally not a number
in there you could show her because even
if it's 100 it's not a mill it's in fact
and if it's not if it's a meal it's not
I've seen accounts you're boring me an
account yeah you're boring me you're
boring me ah anyway yeah you have to be
a footballer you fam you have to be an
athlete there's no other exception you
have to be an athlete right
um this one's tweeted me if you're
single this is definitely targeting guys
yeah if you're single stay single I know
people out here apologizing for taking
naps
that's an unfortunate reality in a lot
of relationships I'm so sorry baby sorry
I missed your call I was sleeping swear
sleeping with who with who is the
question what's got you so tired what
school are you so tired in the middle of
the day it's 4pm while I'm at work and
you're at home coincidence bum you're a
bum bum why are you tired you should be
actively looking for jobs you should be
at the job center you're taking naps you
can't be tired at four oh you can't be
tired at four James yeah yeah because
I've been up since six and I'm alert so
what's got you so tired
babe I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry that's just palpitations
you don't need that's palpitations you
don't need of course not bloody hell
my girl wanted a dog for Christmas so I
cheated on a simple straightforward
that is simple and straight so pull it
straight forward a dog for Christmas wow
I remember one time I told a girl her
rudeness wasn't attractive and she said
genuine question what makes you think
I'm looking to attract you message sent
me to sleep
bro
genuine like a question I couldn't see
the genuine question pop up and then the
three dots yeah what the [__] is she
gonna ask me what makes you think I'm
trying to attract you yeah that I
obviously wouldn't reply yep I almost
because it's there's no point yeah and
I'm just gonna I'm gonna go into the
coziest sleep I've had because I don't
want to wake up
a young apnea and that's it
that's mad
women can be so vicious and they're so
quick
I refuse to believe it's a joke because
it's so quick sometimes
genuine questions genuine one question
why don't you think I'm trying to
attract you of all people you
do you think the love of my life who
will be getting rudeness from me never
do you think man that I'm attracted to
get rudeness from me never
common denominator never there's nothing
like that
trash
anyway Skeen
scheme I would love my phone in my mouth
skin
um
what'd you put on first when getting
dressed reply my shirt reply okay Winnie
the Pooh
bro you can't live like this sure we've
said this bad times [__] just ah Just sh
it just doesn't make sense that's
disgusting
ah
was meant to go on a vacation in June
and even and even though I liked him I
had to cancel because I kept on having
nightmares of him stealing my passport
and leaving me stranded
wow and leaving me stranded you know
this [__] has got trust issues wow all
right vacation
he's gonna steal my past I can't go I
just can't go names may stop looking for
holidays
fly it now I'm just so terrified that
you're gonna steal my password leave me
there strand leave me for dead I'm gonna
look at my phone blocker yeah 100.
you're chatting you're not you're not
the one you're not you're honestly
you're not the one yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right I've got a few more all right
set us
[__] you know
East London is a scary place this man
stuck his middle fingers up at his
reflection in the train door
I stepped but when we was in we was in
East London the other day wasn't it
Stratford Stratford the other day I was
coming to link you to remember
walking past one of the shops and
they've got a window angled wrong okay
so as I'm walking past it I see someone
walking towards me okay so I'm there
they're there the Shop's here I'm
walking walking in my peripheral I can
see someone walking here I stepped back
it was me
it was me it was angled yeah because the
mirror was an angle right it was angled
right here
I stepped back because it was getting
closer and closer closer I was like what
the [__]
it was me bro like a dog seen himself
yeah I've never felt so embarrassed
that's hilarious
what the [__] is he getting so close
babe my personal space for facts
hilarious all right a couple more
a wax lady was definitely playing with
my [__] today but whatever reply why do
people still wax when you can get laser
four times and be done forever reply
because the wax lady plays with [__]
she just said so
oh that's crazy that's crazy just a
little cool what's going on never never
never never never never
mad I lost one why do gay guys shoot
their shots so aggressively man
um quite sweet Sun slow jams was playing
at my job and one day this giant guy
stand me in my eyes and sung Twisters
verse word for word I ran away
slow jams
slow down baby I can do it that fast but
I know somebody who can
twister I don't even remember I didn't
remember how that verse went
um
[Laughter]
wow let me get your sheets wet listening
to Keith Sweat staring at you let me get
your sheets wet listen to Keith Sweat
gorgeous man big guy
stared him down
I said yeah no wonder he ran away
no wonder let me get your shoes
I couldn't have another man look at me
in the eyes and tell me that
where's the wet coming from
[Music]
where's the wet coming from you gonna
make your [__] is that what you're
telling me you're gonna make this your
[__]
big man step back that one step back oh
God
[Music]
foreign